we now come to prime minister's
questions Stephen Thames
thank you Mr Speaker at question number
[Music]
Mr Speaker I know the house will join
the nation in the Commonwealth in
sending our very best wishes to their
majesties the king and queen ahead of
time
this will be a moment of extraordinary
national pride a demonstration of our
country's character and an opportunity
to look to the Future in the spirit of
service unity and hope Mr Speaker this
morning I had meetings with ministerial
colleagues and others in addition to my
duties in this house I shall have
further such meetings later today to
students Mr Speaker question time last
week column 725 the Prime Minister
referred to record numbers of people in
work in fact as he knows a number of
people in work at the moment is still
less than it was just before the
pandemic 122
792 less according to the latest
official figures will he reassure the
house that he's not slipping into the
bad ways of his predecessor but one
and will he properly correct the
incorrect statement he made last week
well Mr Mr Speaker that clarification
has already been made uh Mr Speaker and
Hansard but there are near record
numbers of people in work and in payroll
and that is thanks that is thanks to the
actions of this government Mr Speaker
one record we're very proud of
very much Mr Speaker
um non-compliant hand car washes seem
like a cheap and quick way to have our
cars washed but unfortunately behind
this 1.8 billion pound industry is
hidden money laundering fraud drug
dealing prostitution labor abuse modern
day slavery tax avoidance and many other
Sinister crimes
um this is an estimated half a billion
pound lost in tax revenue a pull factor
for illegal migration and the pollutants
of the news are damaging to the
environment there's a prime minister
agree with me but it's time that we now
step away from the voluntary scheme and
have a mandatory scheme to protect
people
well Mr Speaker we expect all businesses
to follow the law including providing
Fair pay and working conditions for
their employees we're tackling
exploitation in the labor market
especially by increasing funding for
enforcement bodies to over 35 million
pounds a year and we will continue to
keep the position of hand car washes
under close review but how come the
leader of the opposition
thank you Mr Speaker can I join the
prime minister in his comments about the
coronation across the house we're all
looking forward to the celebrations this
weekend
Mr Speaker does the Prime Minister know
how many mortgage payers are paying
higher rates since the Tory party
crashed the economy last autumn
Mr Speaker our record our record on home
ownership is crystal clear because of
our tax cuts 90 of first-time buyers now
don't pay any stamp duty at all Mr
Speaker and last year we saw the largest
number of people buying their first home
in 20 years Mr Speaker that's a
conservative government delivering on
people's aspirations to own their own
home
Mr Speaker the question was how many
people are paying more on their
mortgages each month and the answer that
the Prime Minister avoided giving is 850
000. nearly a million people paying more
on their mortgage each month because his
party used their money as a casino chip
that's why George Osborne called them
economic vandals who created a
self-inflicted financial crisis
not not for the Prime Minister and his
non-domsing
not for the super wealthy they gave tax
cuts to but for mortgage holders all
across the country
so does the Prime Minister know how many
more people will be joining them on
higher mortgage rates by the end of this
year
of inflation have now eased to a
15-month low Mr Speaker consumer
confidence is at the highest level that
it's been at since Russia invaded
Ukraine and
says we can see a clear way to reduce
debt and bring interest rates down but
Mr Speaker he keeps in this habit of
quoting the former labor Shadow chances
we know that our plans will deliver
lower inflation and lower interest rates
but we know we know that his plans his
plans just mean more debt Mr Speaker and
I quote and I quote year after year
after year those aren't my words that's
the assessment of the former labor
Shadow Chancellor
Mr Speaker the question was how many
more people this year are going to be
paying more on their mortgages
and the answer that he avoided giving
again he knows these answers he's he's
got the stats there in front of him 930
000 people so by the end of this year I
know they don't want to talk about it
that's why he won't answer the questions
by the end of this year nearly two
million homeowners counting the cost of
the tourist economic vandalism with
every mortgage payment they make
and it's not just those who already own
their home that are counting the cost of
Tory recklessness the average deposit
for a first-time buyer is going up to 9
000 pounds
does he even know how long it would take
an average saver to put that sort of
money aside
[Applause]
the Mr Speaker it's why we're helping
people in social housing own their own
home through our first homes and our
shared home ownership schemes but Mr
Speaker I said like I said these things
are working because I said last year we
had a record number of first-time buyers
the highest number in 20 years it was Mr
Speaker twice the number of first-time
buyers then labor ever managed Mr
Speaker so whilst labor failed
homeowners the conservatives are
delivering for them
Mr Speaker every week whatever the topic
he stands there and pretends everything
is fine across the country and every
week he does so he reinforces just how
out of touch he is
nine thousand pounds hahaha nine
thousand pounds would take four years
they think it's funny that hope nine
four years
for the average saver to save nine
thousand pounds or or to put it a
different way in terms the Prime
Minister will understand roughly the
annual Bill to heat his swimming pool
people for most people
four more years of scrimping is a hammer
blow to their ambitions and now he's
kicking them when they're down because
his decision to scrap housing targets is
killing the dream of home ownership for
a generation why doesn't admit he got it
wrong and reverse it
Mr Speaker I promise to put local people
in control of new housing and I'm proud
that that's what I delivered within six
weeks of becoming prime minister now he
wants to impose top-down housing targets
he wants to concrete over the green belt
and ride roughshod over local
communities now previously Mr Speaker he
did say he's on record and saying local
people local communities should have
more power more control now he's
u-turned just another in a long list of
broken promises
speaker the only Power is given to local
communities not to build houses
and we know why he won't change course
he admitted it last month his counselors
simply don't want to build the houses
local people need so he's given them a
way out
picture of the scene as he explains this
to a family mum and dad paying four
grand extra on the mortgage because the
tourists tanked the economy their eldest
paying hundreds more in rent their
youngest still stuck in the spare room
because they need an extra 9 000 pounds
for a deposit then along times the Prime
Minister unmarily tells them
sorry for crashing the economy but we
don't want to talk about that
sorry I can't help you with the house
building
oh here's a massive council tax increase
for your troubles while Daphne stop the
excuses stop blaming everyone else and
just build some houses instead
Mr Speaker our memories on on that short
we all know what happened last time
where they're in power there was no
money left for the country
about the record let's talk about the
labor record on house building Mr
Speaker in London the former
conservative mayor built 60
000 affordable homes in his first five
years in office how many do the current
labor labor mayor manage half of that Mr
Speaker
in in Wales we need 12 000 new homes a
year how many have Labor built in the
last year half of that Mr Speaker
as ever labor talk and the conservatives
deliver
Mr Speaker
debt doubled since 2010 growth down tax
up the economy crashed Mr Speaker
they're gonna need a bigger note
foreign
[Applause]
but looking beyond the elections
tomorrow we also have a hugely
significant weekend coming up with the
king's coronation
for most this will be the first time
they've seen a monarch crown
and I hope and I know across the Hope
House people will hope help people
across the country enjoy the ceremony
the street parties and of course the
extra day off
300 million will tune in the world will
see our country at its best
celebrating the beginning of a new
chapter in our history
but there will also be a reminder of the
loss of our late Queen Elizabeth II
and a chance again to remember all that
she gave to our country through her
dedicated service
so will a prime minister join me in
honoring our late Queen and wishing the
new king a long unhappy reign
[Applause]
Mr Mr Speaker as as I said at the outset
we're all looking very much forward to
the coronation it'll be a very special
moment in the history of our country and
I know that we will joined with the
country in celebrating it but before we
get to the coronation weekend Mr Speaker
we have an important day tomorrow and
the choice before the country is clear
when they go to that Ballot Box they can
see a party that stands for higher
council tax higher crime and a Litany of
broken promises Mr Speaker Meanwhile
we're getting on we're delivering what
we say with a lower council tax lower
crime and fewer potholes the choice is
clear vote conservative Mr Speaker
thank you Mr Speaker
labor run kirkley's Council Mr Speaker
as you know have reneged on a deal to
house the national rugby league museum
at The George Hotel
they've also declared a climate
emergency but they have one of the worst
recycling rates in the country
they're building on green fields and now
on Green Belt they're demolishing home
Firth indoor market we're blighted by
litter and fly tipping and now they're
proposing to chop down mature trees in
urban areas just oh Mr agree with me no
you'll sit down tomorrow I presume
you're gonna ask the question you've
been a Grace name great question as the
Prime Minister agree with me that local
people can have their say on kirkley's
appalling record by voting conservative
this week
Mr Speaker my honorable friend is
absolutely right it's typical labor
saying one thing and doing the other Mr
Speaker
it's only the conservatives that are
going to protect the green belt it's a
labor party they're gonna concrete over
it and that's why in kirkles and
elsewhere tomorrow vote conservative Mr
Speaker
through the SMP Stephen Flynn
Mr Mr Speaker in 2010 David Cameron
convinced Nick Clegg to drop his Pledge
on University tuition fees does the
Prime Minister intend to take the credit
for convincing the leader of the labor
party to do likewise
[Applause]
prime minister
well I I Thank The Honorable gentleman
for the question
it I'd say it's it's hard to keep up Mr
Speaker with a list of broken promises
but I would say oh on tuition fees is
I'm proud but under this government we
now have a record number of people that
are going to University from
disadvantaged backgrounds Mr Speaker and
that's because the efforts we've paid to
put more money into supporting those
people and those communities to fill
their aspirations alongside fantastic
new apprenticeships in every part of our
country
Mr Speaker for the avoidance of any
doubt the liberal Democrats don't
believe in abolishing tuition fees the
conservatives don't believe in
abolishing tuition fees and of course
the labor party now with their own neck
leg moment don't believe in abolishing
tuition fees
is it is it not the case that the main
Westminster parties don't offer Young
offer young people any hope at all do
they
actually actually I'll gently point out
to The Honorable gentleman that if
you're from a disadvantaged background
you're far more likely to go to
university in England than you are in
Scotland
thank you Mr Speaker the conservative
the the conservative police and crime
commissioner endorse it has delivered
174 new police officers he's quadrupled
the rural crime team and has made Dorset
the sixth safest County yeah as recorded
crime is 34 higher under labor police
and crime Commissioners does a prime
minister agree with me that only
conservatives can be trusted to keep
local communities safe and make sure
offenders face the Justice they deserve
oh Mr Speaker honorable friend is right
it's a simple statement of fact crime is
lower in areas which have conservative
police and crime Commissioners and I'm
delighted that doors that have been
selected as one of the areas to Pilot
our new immediate Justice scheme which
will deliver Swift and visible
punishment to victims of anti-social
Behavior know that it will be treated
seriously and with all urgency Caroline
Lucas thank you very much Mr Speaker his
government's vile and immoral Refugee
ban bill and the toxic language coming
from the home office isn't even dog
whistle politics it is a giant hard
right Foghorn blasting out of poisonous
them in US narrative and it plumbed new
depths last week when the home office
Minister claimed that people trying to
come to the UK and I quote tend to have
completely different values to those in
the UK can you explain what he thinks
are so different about the values held
by the people of water torn Sudan and
can you tell us what values are stopping
him from creating a Sudanese family Visa
scheme like he did for the people of
Ukraine
Mr Speaker this country has a proud
history of welcoming almost half a
million refugees over the past several
years and we will always continue to do
so but our ability to do that is
absolutely hampered when we have tens of
thousands of people illegally crossing
the channel every year and it's
precisely because we want the help the
most vulnerable people whether they be
in Syria and Afghanistan so down and
elsewhere we must get a grip of this
problem break the cycle of the criminal
gangs and Target our resources and
compassion on those who most need it
thank you Mr Speaker thanks to this
conservative government and 1.8 million
pounds from the Brownfield land release
fund the conservative LED solihull
council is getting on with regenerating
King says Village Center creating space
for new businesses and new homes but
when it comes to economic regeneration
none of the opposition parties have a
viable plan not the greens not the
and the labor candidate has gone so far
as to scare local people into thinking
that the development won't go ahead
despite Spades in the ground so does the
prime minister mystery with me while the
opposition talk down opportunity the
creation of jobs when it comes to
investing in our communities it's only
the conservative LED solihull Council
Mr Speaker I agree with my honorable
friend and I'm so glad to see the local
conservatives delivering for the people
of solihull with dozens of new family
homes new flexible commercial space and
a new Integrated Health social care and
Community Hub as he said it's clear for
his local area only the conservatives
can deliver
yeah yeah Mr Speaker imagine seeing a
car in front of you narratively or
suddenly breaking for no reason risking
your car slamming into the back of that
endangered no staff enough not to wear
seat belts now this is not the actions
of a drunk a reckless driver but Mark
and Stitch the experience using Tesla
and autopilot mode software installing
beta phase with dim Circle for Carson or
public roads while the Prime Minister
meet with me to discuss issues with
Tejas autopilot and instigate an urgent
critical safety review in terms of its
suitability for operation and the
licensing over yeah yeah Mr Speaker I'm
sorry to hear about what happened to the
remembrance constituent I'll ensure that
he gets a meeting with the transport
secretary to discuss the safe regulation
of autonomous and self-driving vehicles
[Applause]
City of Lincoln Council has destroyed
the 40-year reputation of our City's
Christmas Market and the Christmas
cheers that Lincoln benefits for
manually the dereliction of their role
chooses to take the easiest option
behind closed doors in secret in
canceling the market shows laborers
neglect and disregard for small local
businesses Charities and entrepreneurs
and voters labor councils linkage will
be ashamed of their actions yeah and
have rightly been likened to the great
order Mr Brendan I don't need to
shouting for the bank roll I've always
offered a cup of tea to this side but
it's equally opportunity for you to take
one common
I thank the member from the opposite
side for the extra minutes he's giving
me Mr Speaker
tomorrow the people of Lincoln will have
the chance to remember I will not count
on that
tomorrow the people illegal have the
chance to remove from office the
anti-business Socialist cruises
local conservatives does my right
honorable friend the Prime Minister
agree with me that for better run local
Services they this is
the Prime Minister I think the text went
out I think he's got the answer
Mr Mr Speaker I share my honorable
friend's disappointment that after a
decision taken by the labor on Council
behind as he said closed doors there
will no longer be a Christmas Market in
Lincoln ending its 40 Years of History
Lincoln deserves better and I urge the
people of the city to vote conservative
well thank you Mr Speaker ahead of
tomorrow's local elections I've been
campaigning in Medway in Swindon the
words on the doorstep is that people are
ready for a change and we'll be
switching their votes from the
conservatives to labor
however I am concerned that only four
percent of those without valid ID have
applied online for a voter Authority
certificate so will the Prime Minister
commit to a post-election review of how
many people have effectively been
disenfranchised by his government's
response to the virtually non-existent
problem of votes of frauds
[Applause]
Mr Speaker 98 of people already possess
a suitable form of voter ID and the
government made available free
alternative ID for those that do not
have it the pilots have demonstrated it
hasn't that's a typically impacted
turnout and indeed this was a policy
that was introduced by the labor party
in Northern Ireland all those years go
and
it's common it's common in European
countries it's common in Canada and it's
absolutely right that we introduce it
here too
Mahindra yeah thank you Mr Speaker it's
getting elected in 2019. I've been
inundated with correspondence for my
constituents in Southwest Hertfordshire
rightly complaining about huge
speculative developments on our
beautiful Greenbelt Land
lip time controlled Three Rivers
District Council continue to dither And
Delay their local plan does he agree
with me that the choice tomorrow is
simple very conservative to protect our
Green Belt although lib them for massive
developments on on sport land
well Mr Speaker honorable friend raises
an important point and it's always the
same with liberal Democrats saying one
thing and doing the other we've all seen
it Mr Speaker it's the conservatives
that a party of local decisions taken by
local people and it's only the
conservatives that will protect the
green belt
thank you Mr Speaker unable to secure an
NHS dental appointment my constituent
Ray was forced to go private it was then
discovered that he had a large
aggressive tumor in his face and jaw
which required 16 hours of grueling
surgery to remove it if it hadn't if he
hadn't been able to afford it Ray might
not be with us now this is yet another
chapter in the horror story that is the
decay of Dentistry under this
government's watch so will the Prime
Minister accept NHS Dentistry is in
crisis and will he meet with me and the
British Dental Association to ensure
that no one loses their life because
they couldn't get a dental appointment
uh Mr Speaker I'm sorry to hear what
happened to The Honorable ladies
constituent and that's why the NHS has
recently reformed Dental contracts to
improve access we now invest over three
billion pounds a year there are over 500
more dentists working in the NHS this
year than last year and indeed
discussions are ongoing between the
department for health and the NHS around
dentistry and dhsc is planning to
outline further reform measures in the
near future so definitely Clifton blow
every single young person that gets on
the housing ladder under a conservative
government makes our communities more
sustainable when my rider or friend
agree that in order to build the right
type of Housing and speed it up we need
to fund planning authorities properly
through Innovative funding
well Mr Speaker my uh honorable friend
as ever makes an excellent point and
that's why the reforms that we introduce
will provide incremental resources to
planning authorities to make sure that
planning decisions can be taken quicker
but all also we've strengthened the
ability of local communities to put in
place local plans Mr Speaker this is the
best way for our town cities villages to
have control over development in their
area and make sure that it happens in
the way that they are comfortable with
and I know that he's supportive of that
too absolutely thank you very much Mr
Speaker the recent ITV documentary life
and death stories from the edge followed
Halifax mum Izzy her pre-term and energy
bills have tripled and she was relying
on a local Primary School ash green
we're providing free breakfast budget
cooking classes and a hardship fund for
their families when head teacher
Shepherd is asked does he worry about
the children at school when he goes home
at night he says all the time it never
leaves you does the Prime Minister think
it's right that things are so bad that
schools are having to become the fourth
emergency service for the families
well Mr Mr Speaker because of the
actions we've taken a typical family
including those like Izzy's will be
seeing half of their energy bills paid
for by the government that is support
worth 1500 pounds extended in the most
recent budget for the most vulnerable in
our society there's additional support
and 900 pounds for those on welfare Mr
Speaker and through the holiday activity
and food program support for families
with the cost and support for food
during the holidays but I would also say
for Izzy and others they're in
particular need they should talk to
their Council because the chancellor has
provided over a billion pounds of
funding to the household support fund
it's there to help families like that
that need a little bit of extra
assistance during this time so John
which team did thank you Mr Speaker as
my original friend will be aware today
is World Press Freedom day at a time
when the need for professional and
factual journalism has never been
greater well my my writable friend
reaffirmed the government's commitment
to defending media Freedom world wide
and will he redouble the efforts of the
government to obtain the release of Evan
gerskovic and Vladimir karamerza in
Russia and of Jimmy Lai in Hong Kong
uh Mr Speaker the government is
committed to defending media Freedom
worldwide because thriving independent
journalism is one of the cornerstones of
democracy we absolutely condemn the
politically motivated sentencing of
journalists across the world and our
embassies and missions work every day to
protect media Freedom where they are
based and I know that this is something
that my right honorable friend has been
a right champion of throughout his
career and I will look forward him
continuing to do so from a different
perch as I take rather fewer questions
from him over the next few months from
this position the kennel
country this weekend to support the
coronation events but police numbers in
the Northeast are down eight percent
since 2010 and I know the prime
minister's keen on his maths so here's a
sum
if northumber police has lost a thousand
to police officers since 2010 but gained
the funding to put back 615 by how much
have the conservatives shortchanged the
Northeast
[Applause]
[Music]
so Mr
Mr Mr Speaker Mr Speaker as we saw last
week there are now a record number of
police officers across the country
thanks to the actions of this government
and Prime is 50 lower than it was when
we took office she talks about investing
she talks about investing in the
Northeast you know when we when we
invested leveling up Fund in her
constituency 20 million pounds she said
it was transformational Mr Speaker she
said it would play an important role in
rejuvenating her local area that's this
conservative government delivering not
just for the Northeast but for her
constituents too
Mr Speaker I was pleased to welcome the
Secretary of State for transport to
Newsome recently this was to see the
progress on the Northumberland line with
my right honorable friend agreed with me
that this conservative government and
conservative government only is
committed to development of this line
keeping leveling up on track
well Mr Speaker honorable friend has
been a fantastic fantastic Champion for
the restoration of this line indeed it
was one of the first deliveries from the
restoring your Railways fund and it will
be fantastic for his local communities
because that connectivity will provide
jobs opportunity and employment
particularly for young people in his
local area and after years if not
Decades of neglect it's this
conservative government that is
delivering for the people in his local
area
thank you Mr Speaker over 3.6 million
women born in the 1950s had their
pension age increased without their
knowledge and many like my constituent
unknowingly gave up work at 60 only to
realize they had no income they couldn't
pay their bills and some have even lost
their homes so my constituent asked the
Prime Minister today will he commit to
the fair and fast payment of any
compensation that is recommended by the
Parliamentary and Health Service
Ombudsman to 1950s women for the
Injustice they have suffered due to
Administration by the department for
work and pensions
yeah Mr Speaker this issue has been long
discussed in this place and obviously
The Honorable lady knows there's an
ongoing process which I can't comment on
but rest assured of course we will
respond appropriately to any
recommendations that come our way
[Applause]
I'd like to draw the attention of the
prime minister so the dangers of
asbestos in workplace buildings please
would you back the don't let the dust
settle campaign for the Miso Tea Leoni
UK charity in my constituency by setting
up a register of all workplaces in the
country that contain asbestos and
determine a timetable of eradication of
this terrible substance
or Mr Speaker can I thank my honorable
friend for raising this important issue
the law does require Duty holders to
assess whether asbestos is present what
condition it is in and whether it gives
rise to a risk of exposure and they must
drop a plan to manage this risk which
must include removal if it can't be
safely managed where it is located but I
commend her for a continued campaigning
on this important issue
thank you very much Mr Speaker Nick
swims regularly in the Thames at
shepparton but after a recent dip he
found himself hospitalized with
cellulitis for 13 days his doctors think
this was caused by polluted water Mr
Speaker what caused that polluted water
well because Thames water dumped filthy
sewage just days earlier nearby so can
the Prime Minister tell Nick and
everybody else why does he think it's
okay for water companies to keep
polluting our Rivers for another 25
years
Mr Speaker it was just last week but it
was clear there's only one party that's
going to protect the environment and
it's the conservative party a Mr Speaker
that's that's why we've given the
environment agency more powers of
enforcement that's why we're moving to
unlimited fines and that's why we've got
a clear plan to increase investment and
increase monitoring as sewage overflows
it was all right cynicism and hypocrisy
of the party opposite
they could not even show up to support
those plans Mr speaker
thank you Mr Speaker Albert constituents
face host pipe fans after red torrential
spring stalls and asking me why water
catchment plans have not prevented this
reservoirs desalination plants and other
natural catchment structures require
Society where geography and geology
allows is there a natural strategy and
implementation plan to increase water
catchment and enable cross-water company
water transfer to match Regional demand
to supply
yes well Mr Speaker water companies
publish Water Resources management plans
which show how they will continue to
provide a secure supply of water for
customers and I understand that they
have been Consulting on their latest
drafts of these plans and in my
honorable friends particular area of
Devon and Cornwall where temporary use
bands are in place defra and the water
Regulators are closely working with
Southwest water to ensure that the
company is taking all appropriate
precaution reaction to ensure that water
supplies remain resilient this year
that's all for now on prime minister's
questions